The part of the poem actually has a reference to the bell tolling,
which is kind of an earring.
Um,
totally unplanned I think,
but nonetheless,
very strange accidental,
uh,
connection to for whom the bell tolls.
So Phalon very word is like a bell to told me back from the to my soul self.
Uh,
do the fancy,
cannot cheat so well as she is fame to do deceiving Elf.
So,
you know,
even from,
um,
the one with,
uh,
Fitzgerald himself was reciting that beauty can not keep that the of language
here.
And um,
and what is actually in the kid's porn that,
um,
is once again as a tolling of about hauling your former self back to you.
Um,
there's normal is very much about,
um,
decline about loss of what used to be yours.
This is the story.
The tender is the night is telling someone with tremendous promise early on in
his life,
but basically losing it gradually.
And it is that subtraction,
the process of subtraction,
um,
things being taken away from him that the novel chronicles.
So,
um,
there's an awful,
you know,
I'm sure you're sick of this,
but there's point can very much be read within the paradigm of half and half,
not the guy for,
and I don't think I'm,
you know,
you probably,
well,
any case,
it will be very interesting,
very useful to think about deep dive.
But once again,
if yet another example of someone who's struggling between those two posts,
um,
have and have not.
Um,
but,
um,
the novel's only begins no very different note,
right?
Again,
sort of very glamorous French Riviera.
Um,
and in fact it's Moto on a very glamorous couple,
Gerald and Sara Murphy.
Um,
and so,
you know,
actually we can't really see how magical they were,
but apparently they had this circle of friends around them.
Um,
and every day was,
uh,
was a special day.
So,
um,
but,
uh,
so the novels mostly attributed that in further was a show in the bond care.
Uh,
um,
I think it was a couple of years ago,
calm making it new.
Um,
the odd,
uh,
of Gerald and Sara Murphy very much attributed to this very,
charismatic couple.
Um,
but in fact is Joe didn't have to look too far.
I'm in,
he and his wife seldom were quite charismatic as well.
Um,
and um,
certainly if very,
very much part of that world is there's a,
there's an,
an a PBS,
um,
feature on Fitzgerald and this image was actually taken from it.
And this is another image of Fitzgerald,
his daughter,
Scottie,
and sell the,
the French Riviera 1926.
And those were really the productive years,
the Great Gatsby,
and can come out in 25.
And then he was working on this when he was at the French Riviera.
Um,
but as we read on,
we know that in fact,
um,
that calamity or,
and that magic,
um,
probably will not sustainable.
So it's plus Novelis very much about sustainability.
Um,
how long can that last?
and uh,
so,
um,
this,
uh,
in in the funniest is almost implicit in the way that they were thought of as
the golden couple.
Um,
and,
um,
Dorothy Parker and other well known novelist said that they did both look as
though they had just stepped out of the sun.
So you know,
the science that they lived in this completely like field.
Well,
um,
but this a different way in which being in the sun,
that again has a different meaning in Fitzgerald's career.
Um,
and it turned out that in fact his only successful,
hugely successful novel with his first novel and even the Great Gatsby is we
know,
didn't sell all that well in his own lifetime.
It was other printing,
but before he died in Israel until they short life.
Um,
so Fitzgerald knowledge who,
um,
just to make a living,
had to have other jobs and he was a screenwriter in Hollywood,
um,
in the,
in the 30th.
Um,
and so there are a number of books written about Fitzgerald as a screenwriter,
um,
this,
some time in the sun,
but it pretty much is kind of an ironic,
um,
reference to being in the sun is we can see from the pictures,
Ashley now such a glamorous thing to be a screenwriter in Hollywood.
You're stuck with your typewriters.
So the phrase that was used for all the screenwriters,
including Fitzgerald,
including Faulkner,
um,
as we know,
for all the people was that they were hacked with the Underwood typewriter.
There were hack writers,
um,
not having a lot of control over the material.
Um,
here is another book about Fitzgerald and Hollywood,
and this is the picture of him in the 30th.
Um,
struggling pretty much,
um,
this is a very important collection of Fitzgerald's screenplays.
2000 pages at the University of South Carolina.
Um,
and Fitzgerald himself actually also wrote 17 stories that were published in
Esquire magazine,
um,
in early,
while between January,
1942 may,
what do you want?
And then he died after that.
So it was probably a nationally published after the staff,
but they're the pet hobby stories.
There are 17 stories about the screenwriter and down in,
out screenwriter in Hollywood,
um,
and basically very alcoholic,
so a way autobiographical.
Um,
and so we know that film Ashley was front and Center,
um,
for Fitzgeral,
pretty much from the twenties through the 30th and till very much till the end
of his life.
So,
um,
is,
is really,
is throwing an organic part of his career.
So what I like to do today is to talk about,
um,
the ways in which a cinematic techniques get translated into linguistic and
chore,
um,
techniques and especially in one to look at two phenomenon flashback,
which is very much something that was used in Hollywood films,
um,
but also loaned harsh something that actually was used more in European films,
especially in the Russian cinema.
But we're gradually making its way to,
to mainstream Hollywood film as well.
Um,
so the,
the,
the structure for today's lecture,
I'll begin with the publication history,
um,
of the tender is the night,
which actually the first came out in Mac in the magazine.
And then the two additions,
the first edition has a flashback.
Um,
and the addition 51 addition much later,
um,
actually,
uh,
turn it into a chronological narrative.
And what we see today actually in some restoration to that 1934 edition with the
flash back.
And I'll give you the details of that.
Um,
so because the narrative order of Hendra has been,
that is in some sense switchable or reversible,
we'll be looking at a phenomenon or switch ability or reversibility.
Um,
in three ways.
One is looking at sequence of adjectives,
um,
how they are reversible.
Uh,
we'll be looking at the relation between actor and assessory or appendage and
we'll be looking at in relation to training proper nouns and um,
active verbs.
So I'll grammatical relation or kind of reversibility of promedica relation and
then we'll be looking at montage as a technique and the way the data's,
um,
played out in thematic ways.
Um,
but first of all,
the publication history of tenderness night,
um,
with fair used to this.
Others quite often would publish first in magazine.
So came out in four installments,
um,
in Scribner's magazine.
And Scribner's was also a published,
um,
the novel in 34.
So this is the first edition,
um,
are from that of the,
of the novel.
And then I publish,
came out in as a them addition though the 5 cents in 1951.
So the two additions,
there's a huge difference between the two additions.
The 34 edition book one begins and 1925 and then this will jump back to eight
years ago back to 19 and 17.
Um,
so it begins basically with dig diver and this family,
the French Riviera,
and then it goes back when he was just a young doctor,
that just the beginning,
very beginning of his career as we'll promise 1917 and then it goes back to a
later point of the slide.
And I didn't do this.
Um,
so this is the,
um,
the,
the addition that was Polish that Fitzgerald originally published.
Um,
and some critics objected to this hour of sequence.
there's not from a logical narrative.
So when it came out as the Benton classic,
that was switched and it began chronologically began with Dick Divers,
early promise as a young doctor and just proceed as per last week.
So reversing the order of,
um,
of the 34 edition.
Um,
and we're eliminating the flashback.
So,
um,
we can talk a little bit,
in front of would encourage you to think more in session about why it is
important for since general,
um,
to have the flashback one effect is achieved by having a narrative that is our
sequence.
Um,
and um,
I hope that I'll be talking a little bit about that,
um,
in the lectures as well.
But I will encourage you to have your opinion really about this.
Um,
but today I want to concentrate cause we haven't wrestle foreign to the novel.
I want to concentrate,
um,
on switch ability or reversibility asked.
The relatively small scale phenomena is not so much looking at the narrative
form as reversible,
um,
but looking at very minute details,
within the novel that are reversible.
So order of appearance of agitators,
um,
can be seen as frivolous about.
This is just one example.
There is her on the other side,
a young woman lay under the roof of umbrella,
was making out of list of things from a book open on the sand.
Her bathing suit was pulled off her shoulders and her back or ruddy orange,
brown sell off by a string of creamy pose showing me in the sun for phase was
Han and lovely and beautiful.
Okay.
So those adjectives don't go together.
Usually they are not seen in such close proximity,
hard and lovely and Pinnell fall.
Um,
and just to have those three adjectives there,
um,
land up in that particular way generates a kind of a mini narrowed narratives.
So this is one way and wisdom wonder,
um,
of appearance of additives is a case of a confident mini narrativize station of
a disruption,
even though it seems to be just descriptive.
Nonetheless,
this implicit narrative suggested by that order of appearance and the narrative
would be different if we were to reverse to water if her phase where pitiful and
lovely and hod will be different narratives,
right?
So less and Fitzgerald is not going to let those adjectives go as well as they.
Um,
so,
um,
let's right here we see this,
we also have this additional image,
um,
that she's,
her shoulders and back out ruddy and Orange Brown.
And there's a string of premier post,
um,
around the neck.
Um,
when Fitzgerald comes back to this detail,
he does something else for that detail.
So this is him revising himself all the time,
revising as many narrative all the time.
Nicole driver diver,
her Brownback hanging from her pose was looking through a resume book for
chicken,
Maryland,
her brown bag hanging from the truth before it was the hanging around her neck.
All of a sudden there's a rouge losable relation to train the actor and the
appendage so that it is hope wrong back that is hanging from the post were
suggested,
suggested the pose I buy important and maybe money is very important.
It really is about whether the money is more important than human being,
um,
or vice versa.
So once again,
this more than in fact more than just a minute narrative and the kind of the
whole vision of the world who version of the relation to train humanity and
economy is suggested by the very,
very micro detail of the reversible relation to train back and post.
Um,
and so,
you know,
I would say the responsibility is really the key player.
Um,
all through the novel is,
operates on all scales,
operates between adjectives,
operate between different books,
you know,
the three main books of the novel,
and it operates on the shape of the diverse career.
So very,
very important concept.
But just to give you one more example of a very local micro instance,
um,
of switcher go,
or they have reversibility has to do with the transitive relation between proper
names and active verbs.
So we know that this character in a novel called Dick Diver,
um,
and here's Rosemary,
the actress talk to me about what she does and what she has to do.
Um,
she has a fever,
uh,
but because the satisfy expensive,
they just have to,
they just have to shoot up.
So,
um,
this is what she has to do it,
she has to dive into the water for that,
uh,
for that episode.
One day I happened to have the grip and didn't know it and they were taking a
scene where I dove into a canal in Venice.
It was a very expensive set.
So I had to dive and dive and dive on it.
It obviously is not a trivial or unconnected detail in novel where the
protagonist is called Dick Diver,
the distributes someone else diving and diving and diving because of her
discipline as an actress.
So,
um,
I think that that is the right then and there the question opens up is who is
more capable as of,
of,
of a kind of sustainable performance.
Uh,
it seems that just the repetition of those three was dive and dive and dive or
more than suggest that rosemary is probably going to be an actress who would
have a long career because she's so disciplined and you know,
just hardworking,
um,
that,
that if she has to do some things,
you would do it.
Um,
and so the,
the,
the question then,
because she seems to have such a sustainable career,
sustainable performance,
um,
whether deep dive or is capable of that sustainable performance,
the person who has been proper name,
whether he can actually live up to the promise of his name,
Dick died or,
um,
so,
I one how to really sit in on those two agitators hard and tearful.
Um,
and look at the way fish Gero really spins out a whole narrative.
Basically,
you know,
maybe the whole novel,
um,
is based on the interplay between those two adjectives.
So let's look at what the hub Nicco does,
um,
and what comes through,
you know,
what,
what kind of story emerges when we go along the access of Nicco as a hard
person.
This is what she says to Rosemary.
I'm just talking casually,
you know,
about the,
the,
the beach and so on and about the tours.
Um,
well,
I have felt there were too many people on the beach this summer.
Nicole admitted beach that day made out of a pebble,
Pio.
She considered it.
And then during her voice of range of the trio of Nannies who sat back under
another umbrella.
Still,
they're preferable to those brothers last summer who kept shouting about,
isn't this the blue?
Isn't the Sky White?
Isn't a little Nellie's Bros.
Red Rosemary thought she would not like to have Nicole,
Fran enemy.
Um,
so think that this is a great demonstration of a hard person without this person
as are you lifting a finger to do thing right?
It's just the way her mind works.
It is who tone of voice it is,
the way she thinks about Nannies,
uh,
people in her employed the ways.
There's two things about people who don't have the claim to the beach that she
does,
uh,
is really the swish pattern and a tome of worst of someone who's never not been
on the top of the wall.
Um,
and he looks down on everyone and just putting them in the places.
so this is,
this is the hot Nicole.
Um,
Ashley gives another meaning to her back hanging from a string of posts that may
be really,
this is what the real Nicco is.
It is the fact that she is hanging from the string of pearls,
but they will always be a string of hers for her to hand from that she can
afford to look at the world in this way.
I look at other people in this way and speak in that particular tone of voice
that signals to rosemary.
It takes about two seconds,
the rosemary to know what kind of person she is dealing with.
So sheer,
um,
capsule summary of what a person is without recourse to any action.
Um,
and in fact Nicole doesn't really add and two or three and was a novel.
And even that is not even,
you know,
especially hard kind of action,
whether that's debatable.
Um,
but as is the case with Fitzgerald,
um,
the word heart is not allowed to stand alone,
right?
Because we can't forget that in February three adjectives harder and lovely and
pitiful.
So that kind of permutation,
it's like a dance dance were agitators,
um,
will keep coming up against.
So just a few pages later and now the description of Nicole,
um,
who phase and there isn't time to heart,
has to be in quotation marks,
who phase was hard on western save for the soft grim appear.
There's doubt that look from her green eyes,
right.
So it seems that those antigens and really and waned in Fitzgerald his mind that
he cannot think about Nicole without using that trio lovely as well.
Or maybe they just do a just to two adjectives.
They are the,
the two um,
pose or the spectrum of which she shadows back and forth.
Um,
so because plentiful is so much a companion,
um,
to the adjective hot,
let's look at one instance of the pitiful Nicole and see whether or not there is
an organic connection between the beautiful Nicole and the hot Nicole.
And we have to go back earlier.
So we have to go back to book local forward to book two,
which is backwards in time.
Um,
go back to 1917 when she was a patient.
and,
um,
Dick died on this about two,
well actually here now even we to to do anything for her.
He was just someone who was being consulted about her.
Um,
and she was writing to him,
uh,
when she was in this mental institution,
the cat and die for him.
I'm writing to you because there's no one else to whom I can turn.
And it seems to me if there's fast ago misspelled by Nicole,
if this farcical situation,
it's apparent to one as sick as mean,
it should be apparent to you.
The man who would trouble is all over.
And besides that,
I'm completely broken and humiliated.
If that was what they wanted,
my family has shamefully neglected me.
There's no use asking them for help of headache.
I have had enough and it is simply ruining my health and wasting my time
pretending that what is the matter with my head is curable.
So this is the absolute low one.
Nicole,
she is by herself,
her families in Barrow's shoes in the hands of strangers who paid to take care
of her.
Um,
and who,
who is this person who seems to have his whole life,
a full promise ahead of him,
completely healthy,
um,
uh,
about to be launched into this,
this great career.
Um,
so in one sense it is,
um,
and called and homos object that is someone who really has no future to look
forward to.
Um,
has really no hope,
really has nothing that she can claim extent that
given the fact that we have seen the Hal Nichol,
I think that we should also be a learn a little bit to the suggestion of hotness
even in this moment when Nicole and gets most object.
And I think that in fact that misspelled word farcical was two different
linguistic usage.
Somebody who uses the word faster go that way,
um,
is more in command of the faculties then is suggested by the,
uh,
by the profession of objection.
Uh,
likewise,
um,
it is simply ruining my health and wasting my time.
Someone who would use the phrase ways my time is,
has a different sense of herself.
Um,
then it's suggested by the profession and rejection.
So right there.
Um,
even though it is the telephone,
Nicole who is in the foreground,
um,
an element of hardness is never not on the horizon.
And I think that is really then combination that fissure of wants us to say that
she can be,
she's completely switchable.
If the distance between heartlands and truthfulness is tiny,
she would just go back and forth.
It takes one second for the switch from one to the other.
Um,
so one more instance of the pillar phone and they call and this one is very late
in her life.
So this is in the present for her.
Uh,
Nicole knelt beside the tarps.
Weighing cy wise and size wise is you she pride in as you come to intrude on the
only privacy I have in the world with your son Brett of red blood on it,
I will wear it for you.
Another shame though.
It was such a big thing.
So the word pity is foregrounded.
Um,
but once again,
um,
even though this is Nicole in the mind,
Nicole,
totally out of control.
Um,
Nicole gone crazy again and therefore she has to be medicalized.
This is because it candidate for medicalization,
but even though she's a candidate for medicalization,
um,
she's also quite aggressive as well as we can see.
[inaudible] not so defenseless is not to be able to say some pretty wounding
things to whoever would listen to her.
Um,
so once again,
we have that combination.
The pitiful knows this in the foreground,
but hotness is always lurking very,
very close to the front actually in the background.
Um,
so it's because of that I think is because the distance between the two
switchable platforms is such a small distance,
then I think that the technique of montage,
it's especially helpful,
uh,
to,
um,
to Fitzgerald.
Um,
and as I said before it,
I don't think there was actually a mainstream Hollywood,
uh,
technique we ended 20 years yet,
although it was already theorized by film theory is all over the world.
So we'll give you one instance of that.
But basically montage is a film editing techniques and,
um,
the two things that,
that are central to it on this off and saw them from one narrative into another
and super imposition of one onto another.
So these are the two fundamental elements of montage and Sergei Eisenstein,
um,
the Russian great filmmaker,
in the 20s,
um,
he wrote a lot on montage.
Um,
in fact,
um,
I think that is most people who actually talk about attach go back to answering
sties writing in the 1920s.
So the coin to Eisenstein montage is the nerve of cinema and the collision of
different narratives.
Each sequential element is perceived not next to the other,
but on top of the other [inaudible] not next,
even though even though they are sequential,
even though one comes after the other and basically,
you know,
there's no way we can,
this is how time works.
One thing comes after another.
This is the structure of time.
There's no way we can cap completely do without that or completely undermine
that.
But nonetheless is a way of storytelling that makes that sequential appearance
almost in case of super in position.
Um,
and I think that this is really what Fitzgerald does for a good part of the
time,
the intenders now.
So let's just look at five or six instances of what I would call different moles
of super imposition or super fun,
super imposition,
um,
being met on,
different kinds of thematics that are themselves interrelated.
So,
um,
war with began with Warren in the very beginning of this semester and it turns
out that wall would come back and quite a big way,
um,
and is normal that really otherwise it's nothing to do with war,
right?
This is a novel set in the French Riviera and then basically in,
in various civil in and very low sure is settings.
Um,
so it really has nothing to do with war except that for some reason or keeps
coming up,
a very strange delusions.
So,
um,
one of the first instances of this,
and usually it comes out in casual conversation.
Um,
so sometimes between the major character,
sometime between the of character.
So this is a conversation between Rosemary and Tommy,
Barb and,
um,
who's mercenary?
Um,
actually I didn't know that,
that there was,
there was such an important class of,
of there was such an important profession.
Uh,
but it turns out that that maybe it was in the,
in the early 19th century and early 20th century.
Um,
so Tommy,
uh,
because his nurse in your amp goes around from one place to another home.
I have no home.
I'm going into a war.
What war?
Any war.
I haven't seen the papers lately,
but I suppose there's a war.
There always is.
Don't you care what you fight for?
Not a law.
As long as I'm well treated and I'm in a Rut,
I come to state of divers because then I know that in a few weeks I want to go
to war.
Rosemary's different,
you liked the dye foods?
She reminded him of course,
especially her,
but they made me want to go to war.
Um,
Tommy bothering in mercenary,
but he certainly is not just brute strength.
Psychological solely at play.
Here we,
this is page 30,
so we have no understanding of what context Tommy Bob and his speaking an hour
of all we can say is that it is not an innocent context.
That he has lots of things that he's holding back about how he feels about the
divers is clear that he doesn't like tech diver right now.
That I like them,
especially her.
Um,
but also the general says that,
you know,
that just to seal the two of them for a couple few weeks is enough.
That is enough to make him want to go to war.
We don't know what it is about them that will have this kind of effect on him,
uh,
but it never fails.
Um,
so right then and there,
this is a snake making his way until this paradise that is the French Riviera.
Um,
the leaves,
we can say that even amount,
the close friends and people who are right there who sit at,
you know,
who are there constantly with,
um,
the people who supposedly are very good friends with errors,
have this companion,
um,
about them.
So we have,
this is just one mystery that we have to figure out and the details of which we
have to fill out for ourselves.
And in fact,
I would suggest that even at the very end of the novel,
I'm not sure that we can completely clear up this mystery.
Um,
but it's just saying there and it's the super imposition of love and war,
um,
that creates this particular kind of psychological dynamics between Rosemary and
Tommy.
Um,
and also between Tommy and the divers.
so,
um,
it is,
it is not even visual.
So I just want to emphasize that when,
um,
the film technique of,
of,
of montage is used in the novel,
it doesn't always have to be visual.
It can just be a case of psychological super in position.
Um,
although sometimes a Fisher also use this very,
very visual supine position as well as who will say,
but just to give you one more example of how a persistent Fitzgerald is about,
um,
super imposing these two love and war.
So,
um,
they go and they walk out and it turns out that even here in this,
very,
um,
in,
in this seeming very peaceful setting,
um,
that Ashley,
we're worldwide was fought very close by.
Um,
and so close by that the relics of what we're one,
we're still there.
And this is the spot actually where um,
the British,
um,
could only at Vance I'm a foot at a time.
The risk systems,
um,
was so fierce that they can only move ahead one foot at a time.
Army.
And it caused too many lives today for them to go forward one foot.
So the Lan here cost too many lives of fun.
Past summer he said to Rosemary,
she lived out obedience late at the rather than Behr green plane with a slogan
cheese of six years world.
If Dick has added that there were now being showered,
she would have believed in that afternoon.
Her love her original point.
We're now at last.
She was beginning to be unhappy,
to be desperate.
She didn't know what to do.
She wanted to talk to her mother.
So here Rosemary is deeply in love.
She's in the throes of love,
of,
of what seems to be unrequited love for,
for the um,
and unnecessary background is World War One.
That it is the fact that she would have been,
if he had told her that there would be in shout once again as well,
one that she will have believed him if he has that,
that that is the measure of how much in love she is.
So it seems that love is really not a free standing entity and there's novel is
always mapped against large scale warfare.
We don't simply know the logic of that mapping is not clear.
In fact,
I would also say that this is another of those mysteries that even having,
you know,
even at the Amygdala,
the novel,
we might not be able to see exactly what the logic guests,
but clearly for Fitzgerald,
there's a logic that always persistently resolves in this cross mapping or a
super position of love and work.
Um,
one more example just to see how I'm obsessed.
He is really with this kind of cross mapping.
Um,
general grants though is not just to have a one a but the civil war.
and this is something that Fitzgerald has in common,
uh,
where Hemingway as well in 400 bottles.
We see that the Spanish civil war and the American civil war sometimes cross
mapped dre,
um,
in the importance of rubber Jordan's grandfather here for no reason that we can
see,
um,
the civil war of comes into play in the missile.
The discussion about more one general grant invented this kind of battle at
Petersburg in 65.
No he didn't.
He just invented mass butchery.
This kind of battle was invented by Lewis Carroll and Jews Fun and whoever wrote
and Dean and country deacons,
bowling Mras and Messiah and girls seduced in the back lands who vote timber and
verse failure.
Why this was a love battle.
This was a century of middle class love span here.
This the last love battle,
totally on idiomatic use of the English language.
Love battle is not a phrase that anyone else would use.
Um,
Fish Gero uses it as,
as it were the most idiomatic expression in the world.
And that's because in his mind there is such a tight knit between love and war
that it is this,
you almost cannot talk about one without talking about the other blue calling to
this.
Um,
apparent analysis of war is really middle class romantic love that is at the
back of war is very long because of a change to go from middle class love to
trans warfare or the civil war.
Um,
in the U s history isn't very,
very long call.
So chain we have to fill in lots and lots of relays in all that for that course
or change to make sense.
But that's what Fitzgerald wants us to imagine is to imagine all those missing
links and he's not showing us.
Um,
so this is,
um,
I think that we've seen enough to know that this really is suffering significant
Palin not explained to us,
obviously.
Um,
but that is one of the,
um,
the kind of the constant,
in this novel is that,
um,
extreme,
extreme conditions of love,
uh,
always require a very violent,
large scale file in background.
Uh,
Fred to be fully manifested that maybe his articulation,
uh,
requires some relation to that large scale event.
Um,
so I want to,
um,
turn now to,
talk about,
uh,
we've been looking at the color,
the narrative mapping,
right.
So a large scale,
um,
historical event that's constantly being summoned and reactivated and brought
into novel.
Um,
so this,
this,
this on,
on this,
uh,
of kind of macro register,
um,
that has the micro of romantic relation.
Um,
but it turns out that that combination of love war can also be played out in
very,
very incidental moment,
is not involving the protagonist a law which suggest that,
um,
it is a narrative fabric.
It's a descriptive fabric that Fitzgerald is,
is,
is almost like a stylistic tape for Fitzgerald maybe without even making a huge
thematic point about it.
Um,
that's where his mind resource to whenever he talks about any kind of violence,
there's also this other element of love that is super imposed.
Um,
so this is a totally trivial incident except for the fact that if it shows the
same kind of dynamics,
the Pullman entrance to cause of the vivid scene,
it has itself from the tenor of any farewells,
the young woman with a helmet like hair to whom they call has spoken,
made an odd dodging.
The low run away from the man to whom she was talking and plunge of frantic hand
into a post.
Then the sound to revolve of sharps crack,
the narrow heir of the platform.
But before the crowd closed in the others as saying the shop ticket by saying
the target sit down upon the glass,
um,
people were constantly getting shot,
in this novel,
which is really surprising.
Fat We do is back murder to appear with this kind of regular reality in this
particular kind of social setting.
But it does.
Um,
so that in itself is the very insistent pattern.
um,
DePaul,
the Fitzgerald,
but I want to call attention and is highly cinematic moment.
Um,
the,
um,
the beginning with,
with just,
just to kind of,
you know,
the usual,
uh,
scene at the train station,
people were saying goodbye.
Um,
but really the introduction of a show Alaman that Ashley could be filmed,
uh,
with perfect two to maximum effect the young woman with the helmet light hair,
completely gratuitous detail,
um,
that will not have caught attention to self,
but we're not otherwise have call attention to himself,
but in this novel,
given the certain position of loss and borders,
so it's a helmet like hair,
um,
that who's a total stranger to Nicole then they call it spoken,
made an odd dodging.
The they'll run away from man to whom she was talking and lunge a little frantic
hand her into her purse.
Um,
is that almost Dan steps taken by that,
um,
by that woman.
Um,
is,
is this as a kind of dance movement and then the shot coming after that as not a
predictable,
not expected conclusion to that dance movement that creates this montage.
If I have ray,
she's been talking to Nicole,
um,
she's making a little run.
Um,
maybe,
you know,
we would expect someone who's making a little run in a translation to go and
catch the train,
right?
That's the most usual context for the Volvo run,
except it isn't dodging little run.
And it turns out that the one comes,
the outcome of that little run is in fact the shooting.
So two completely separate narratives being mapped onto one another dude,
much more standard unsurprising narrative was saying goodbye and the train
station with a totally different story being mapped onto it.
And it turns out that the two can actually share a lot of the same visual
details unless there's a diversions and the violence of that diversions that
created that particular cinematic effect.
Um,
so just want to give you one more example of this highly cinematic rendition,
um,
of murder.
Um,
and it turns out that Fitzgerald,
um,
is,
especially interested in the,
um,
the way that the sequence leading up to a murder or the sequence,
by which murder it's founding,
recognized as murder.
So here is a description of something that happens in Rosemary's room,
hotel room,
um,
and it takes a long time to get to the end.
I think that that's the point.
So let's follow visual and this very,
very strange Paris to pastures.
Then rather gradually she realize without turning about that she was not alone
in the room in an inhabited room,
they are reflecting objects.
Only half notice fathers would more or less polished brass,
silver in ivory and beyond this dousing conveyors of light and shadow.
So mild that once ghastly things of them as that the tops of picture frames the
edges of pencils or Ashtrays of Cristo or China honor when the totality of this
reflection appearing to equally Cielo reflexes of the Vision as well as those
association of fragments in the subconscious that we seem to hang on to as a
glass filter keeps the irregularly shaped pieces that may do some time.
This fat,
my account for what rosemary afterward mysteriously described is realizing that
there was someone in the room before she could determine it,
which she did realize it.
She turns with and I saw the ballet step and saw that the Leebro stress that
this has got to be the most for discovery of the body
and work of America,
their Azure.
Um,
it seems almost counter productive,
um,
for the realization on the part of Rosemary there she was not alone in a room to
the fact that yes,
there's a debt Negro,
um,
on in bed.
Um,
why Fitzgerald would want to take that long detour to me actually once again,
is not completely,
um,
uh,
it's not transparent.
Um,
all we can say is that this is the kind of cinematic moment when we sort of know
that something is wrong in the room,
but instead the focus is cat this frozen,
fixated and all this refreshing objects,
Vonage wood ash trays and so on.
All this refreshing artists that actually not reflecting the dead body,
right?
So there's a really weird kind of way in which they're multiple mirrors in the
room or this refreshing services,
but they're not reflecting the central,
the most important,
crucial fact in that room.
That's the split that Bali,
um,
on the bed.
Um,
instead they seems simply to be a kind of a meditation.
I'm on the way that the world comes to us refracted and there are multiple
objects to be doing that.
Um,
just,
just and the relation between that and our subconscious and the relation between
that and our memory.
So almost a kind of a meditation on the way in which our memory is structured by
visual refractions.
Um,
and then finally coming back to rosemary and even then repeating exactly the
same sequence right there.
Still woman the four has this dodging little run before she plunges ahead into
her purse to pull out,
um,
the,
the revolver.
And here rosemary is not going to plunge ahead into a purse,
but she's going to do a little,
um,
ballet dance ballet staff before she discovers that Bobby,
on guys.
So this is all we can say really is maybe just describe and ree,
um,
ree articulate what Fitzgerald is doing is highly deliberate as highly stylized
for the most stylized moments,
um,
consciously,
maybe even heavy handling,
written,
although what,
for what to what Anne is not entirely clear,
but it's one of the most purposeful moments,
um,
and novel.
And so I think that we're obligated to interpret it in some fashion and to
attach to some degree,
a thematic way,
um,
to this,
seemingly inexplicable moment.
Um,
so always just to say the tenant is now is just real challenge to us as much of
a challenge is Faulkner's novels or.